du salut toute celles et ceux qui sont
là ce matin cette amphithéâtre est plein
les outre-mer nous sommes beaux et
nombreux et en attente de République
plus de République plus de sécurité plus
de justice c'est comme vous l'avez dit
président l'islam une question d'égalité
républicaine pour nous c'est aussi à
Mayotte je suis ici en tant que
parlementaire j'ai été pendant plusieurs
années à la tête d'un collectif de
citoyens je suis ici la représentation
la représentative de la population la
population je ne suis pas au Sénat qui
représente les élus alors je vais ici me
faire la voix de la population en vous
faisant part
de mon immense désarroi
on a passé 10 jours d'enfer à Mayotte et
vous en rentrant
on a passé 10 jours d'en faire un
Mayotte où on a vu nos enfants attaquer
dans les bus à la machette
cette nuit
plusieurs plusieurs maisons étaient
incendiées des entreprises et en fait
dans l'indifférence générale
ce qui est le plus dur à vivre pour nous
c'est la solitude qu'on subit et cette
terreur dure depuis des années j'utilise
à dessin le terme de terreur et le
monsieur le Maire a parlé de terrorisme
parce que quand on découpe des gens en
morceaux et qu'on laisse les morceaux
sur la route c'est du terrorisme
quand le procureur ne fait pas appel aux
motif d'acte de barbarie on se demande
où est la justice
je suis en colère parce que Mayotte
appelle à l'aide depuis des années
et que comme d'autres territoires nous
avons voté contre le président Macron et
qu'on a l'impression d'être puni
et laisser face à nous-mêmes
et laisser dans un bain de sang qui en
fait fait tout reculer les investisseurs
fuient les chefs d'entreprise fuient les
familles s'installent dans l'Hexagone ou
dans les départements voisins à la
Réunion
on est en train nous à Mayotte de subir
une crise qui était annoncée
on ne peut plus entendre c'est pas moi
c'est le maire c'est pas moi c'est le
conseil départemental c'est pas moi
c'est l'état c'est pas moi c'est la
police c'est pas moi c'est la
gendarmerie pour mémoire maintenant la
préfecture à Mayotte diffuse les
chiffres zone gendarmerie zone police
j'ai du mal à entendre ce que veut le
représentation le représentant de l'État
à Mayotte en montant les uniformes les
uns contre les autres mais au final
quand vous êtes agressé vous demandez
pas c'est la faute à qui vous voulez de
la justice
pendant tous ces jours de violences à
Mayotte il y a eu une seule arrestation
cette nuit
on parle de mineurs qui sont étrangers
en très grande majorité qui se déplace
par bande de centaines de personnes
centaines de personnes
et une arrestation
voilà donc nous on demande on exige un
choc de souveraineté on exige un choc de
sécurité on demande l'armée on demande
le raid on demande le GIGN vous allez me
dire la prévention tout ça blabla bah
quand on découpe les gens morceaux on a
dépassé le stade de la prévention nous
on peut plus embarrasser des bonnes
intentions et des tabous des uns et des
autres parce qu'on est dedans
et considérer que ce qui se passe à
Mayotte ne concerne pas le résultat
national est une grosse erreur
parce que quand on laisse la République
reculer comme on l'a fait ici en
banlieue après on peut laisser un
département basculer
et dire finalement ce sont des gens
pauvres souvent musulmans un peu noir ça
votre pas très bien c'est pas très grave
mais si parce qu'on crée des précédents
on laisse faire et le message il est
clair parce qu'il a envoyé à toute la
République
on dit à nos uniformes vous vous battez
vous risquez votre vie mais la justice
derrière ne suivra pas les prises de
risques
on dit on en voit plus d'uniformes mais
il y a pas de déploiement de l'armée
pour protéger nos frontières et puis on
a des débats stériles à l'Assemblée je
peux le dire où on va nous dire oui ben
faut protéger faut protéger faut
protéger qui est-ce que parce que
quelqu'un est mineur c'est une victime
perpétuelle même quand il est devenu un
bourreau
est-ce qu'une population qui est laissée
à la main de barbare en culot de courte
n'est pas victime ce sont des questions
graves des questions profondes qui sont
posées à toute la nation et pas
seulement à nous nous sommes sur une île
où vous allez tous dire bah oui mais
elle est un peu particulière nous sommes
tous particuliers donc des questions qui
nous interpellent je vous laisse
terminer
et
merci Estelle Youssoupha merci madame la
députée
[Musique]